und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und bettina schausten
guten abend wir entkommen ihm nicht dem
corinna virus nicht im urlaub nicht in
dieser sendung
bund und länder haben heute neue
maßnahmen zur abwehr beschlossen auch
wenn das infektionsgeschehen in
deutschland unter kontrolle ist und im
europäischen vergleich jedenfalls nie
eine verheerende dimensionen bekam
anders in spanien das zu den am
stärksten betroffenen ländern in europa
gehört in einer bewegenden trauerfeier
in madrid gedachte die spanische
regierung die königsfamilie und viele
gäste aus europa der mehr als 28.000 400
corona opfer die spanien bisher zu
beklagen hat weiße rosen für die den
kampf gegen das virus nicht gewannen
eine ehrung für pfleger und ärzte wie
für alle spanier könig philipp lobte die
disziplin seiner landsleute
während der wochen des harten lockdown
ssten 14 wochen dauerte dieser lockdown
in spanien strenger ausgangssperren hier
stimmte das wort in deutschland hatten
wir genau genommen keinen lockdown auch
wenn sich der begriff eingebürgert hat
wir durften stets das haus verlassen
verbote machen angst und sie erzeugen
abwehren wohl auch deshalb wurde heute
bei den beschlüssen von bund und ländern
das wort ausreiseverbot vermieden
peter kunz wie groß darf ein corona
käfig sein und wie viele menschen darf
man darin einsperren oder an der
bewegung aus dem hotspot heraus hindern
göttingen im juni sowie 19 ausbruch in
einem hochhauskomplex und das wort
ausbruch haben manche bewohner auch
wörtlich genommen gegen ihre quarantäne
regeln immer wieder verstoßen
einer wurde abgeführt wer das pech hat
im hotspot zu leben oder zu arbeiten
muss dort bleiben wenn abgeriegelt wird
bund und länder haben heute einen
spielraum für den radius solcher
sperrgebiete beschlossen
dehnbare corona käfige sozusagen die
gruppe die infekte uns verdächtig ist
wird isoliert und dann getestet
das sorgt dafür dass wir sehr viel
schneller die infektionsketten
unterbrechen und
es ist ein mechanismus auf denen haben
wir uns heute verständigt und der zweite
punkt ist wenn dieses wenn dadurch noch
nicht alle infektionsketten gestoppt
werden können und es unklare
infektionsketten gibt dann wollen wir
eben nicht einfach auf einen landkreis
bezogen dann über beschränkung maßnahmen
reden sondern zielgerichtet die angst
sicher auch der politik dass es solche
eskalationen wie hier in göttingen im
großen stil geben könnte ganze
landkreise absperren
das ist nicht ganz vom tisch aber durch
schnelles lokales abschotten soll es gar
nicht erst dazu kommen wenn die
infektionsketten unklar sind das sind
die wesentlichen kriterien dafür dass so
was notwendig ist und dann muss jeder
bürger verstehen
wir leben in einer pandemie wir müssen
uns alle so verhalten dass wir nach
möglichkeit infektionen vermeiden
wenn es dennoch zu einem großen
ausbruchsgeschehen kommt dann ist es
eine aufgabe auch unseres statischen
gemeinwohls und auch unseres gemeinsinns
als bürger dass wir versuchen die
ausbreitung zu verhindern
hotspot geplagte gegenden wie göttingen
sind froh dass ihnen beim lockdown
spielraum bleibt ich finde schwer
praktikabel tatsächlich für einen
landkreis zu regeln dass man nicht
ausreisen kann das könnten wir gar nicht
kontrollieren das könnten wir nicht
praktizieren wir sind froh darüber dass
wir es umsetzen können wie wir das in
der vergangenheit gemacht haben mit
schneller reaktion nämlich schnell
identifizieren und schnell isolieren wie
hier im auffanglager friedland wo
spätaussiedler aus kasachstan das virus
mitgebracht hatten
friedland wurde drei wochen man zum
engmaschigen corona käfig aber der
ganzen gegend blieben ausgangs und
reisesperren auf diese weise erspart und
seit zwei tagen ist friedland nun auch
offiziell kein hotspot mehr
es ist die klassische geschichte david
gegen goliath ein junger österreicher
schreibt sich auf die fahnen nicht
aufzugeben antworten zu fordern so
aussichtslos erscheint denn sein ehrgeiz
trifft auf einen digital gegangen wie
facebook am ende bekommt max schrems
recht und das nicht nur ein sondern
heute gleich zum zweiten mal mit
weitreichenden konsequenzen für den
datenverkehr zwischen europa und den usa
ein urteil das schon jetzt nach ihm
heißt schrems 2 und das uns alle
betrifft in einer welt der datenströme
in der datenschutz schwer erkämpft
werden muss felix zimmermann erklärt
worum es geht
weltweiter handel bedeutet heutzutage
weltweiter datenaustausch unmengen an
daten fließen darunter viele persönliche
informationen etwa über online einkäufe
unter surfer halten
beispiel facebook fotos nachrichten und
infos über das klickverhalten wandern
aus ganz europa zu facebook in irland
und werden dann an den mutterkonzern
facebook usa übertragen
doch dort sind die daten nicht sicher
amerikanische geheimdienste greifen
massenhaft daten ab dies hatte der
whistleblower edward snowden 2013
aufgedeckt der datenschutz aktivist max
schrems kämpft seit jahren darum dass
die zuständige irische
datenschutzbehörde gegen facebook
einschreitet den grenzenlosen
datentransfer in die usa stockt nun gab
ihm der europäische gerichtshof erneut
recht eine vereinbarung zwischen den usa
und europa die eine einfache
datenübermittlung erlaubte das
sogenannte privacyshield erklärte der
riecht so für ungültig wegen des
geringen datenschutzes in den usa nach
ansicht des gerichtshofs sind
personenbezogene daten die aus der eu in
die usa übermittelt werden nicht
hinreichend vor dem zugriff der
amerikanischen behörden geschützt
max schrems zeigte sich erfreut über das
urteil
die hat wirklich zu 100 prozent alle
punkte wie wir sie gesehen haben auch so
gesehen dass eben privacyshield nicht
geht das aber bei den standard
vertragslosen im einzel fallen
datentransfer möglich ist allerdings
eben nicht an us unternehmen die diese
überwachungsgesetze auch diese
überwachungsgesetze fallen und das sind
eben die großen it provider in vielen
fällen können führen also über standort
vertragsklauseln weiter mit den usa
personen daten austauschen
doch hunderte unternehmen in europa die
auf das bequeme repressiv hielt gesetzt
haben müssen den datentransfer stoppen
viele unternehmen sind auf eine solche
entscheidung schlecht vorbereitet in dem
sinne dass es nicht
möglich sein wird von jetzt auf gleich
alternative mechanismen zu
implementieren es sei denn man
entscheidet sich dazu einen
datentransfer schlicht von heute auf
morgen komplett zu kappen
was aber für viele unternehmen schwer
möglich sein wird doch datenschutz
prüfer müssten aktiv werden wenn die
unternehmen das unter nicht beachten
wir werden sicherlich dann fang
sanktionen verhängen wenn unternehmen
uneinsichtig sind und sagen wir machen
einfach weiter gucken nicht dass man
jetzt nicht von dem tag heute
bis morgen alles umgestellt hat ist
natürlich völlig nachvollziehbar
damit der datentransfer nicht stockt wo
es ein neues abkommen mit den usa her
doch dafür müssten die amerikaner ihr
datenschutzniveau an europa anpassen die
informations toaster geheimdienste
zügeln
die eu kommission ist das skeptisch wir
können keine magie betreiben und die
amerikanischen gesetze von europa aus
ändern
es sind die amerikanischen partner die
darüber nachdenken müssen
nach dem historischen urteil des bgh ist
klar das grundrecht auf datenschutz muss
für eu bürger auch in den usa beachtet
werden wirtschaft und politik stellt das
vor große herausforderungen
ja und da waren wir noch mal einen
moment lang vertiefen felix zimmermann
ist im studio
das urteil ist ja kein reines facebook
urteil aber es betrifft natürlich jetzt
durchaus auch viele facebook nutzer die
sich fragen was jetzt heißt das denn
dass ab sofort die daten alle sicher
sind womöglich gar nicht mehr in die usa
geschickt werden
das kann man leider nur bei einem klaren
nein beantworten denn das beste urteil
nützt nichts wenn die zuständen behörden
ist nicht umsetzen
und hier ist eben zuständig die irische
datenschutzbehörde
die müsste den datentransfer stoppen
dies aber dafür bekannt ausgesprochen
langsam zu arbeiten steht im verdacht
aus protektionistischen gründen facebook
zu schonen
aus wirtschaftlichen gründen überhaupt
es datenschutz immer so ein hase und
igel spiel unternehmen lassen sich immer
etwas neues einfallen warum der
datentransfer doch möglich sein soll
doch langfristig zeigt diese urteil
natürlich so kann es nicht weitergehen
bis dahin bis da die mühlen langsam
mahlen müssen aber facebook nutzer
weiter mit rechnen dass daten abgerufen
werden
dieses schutzschild für mehr privatheit
was da heute gekippt worden ist hat er
ja die eu mit den usa ausgehandelt
und muss jetzt eben den nächsten vertrag
aushandeln wird denn das überhaupt
gelingen dieses urteil des bgh ist für
die eu kommission die das ausgehalten
wie schallende ohrfeige denn der hatte
ja schon einmal gesagt dieses vorgänger
abkommen safe harbor das ist
rechtswidrig der auftrag war also klar
handelt mit den usa etwas aus was
wirklich die eu rechte die bürgerrechte
effektiv schützt da sind sie auf ganzer
linie gescheitert
und jetzt wird es wirklich darauf
ankommen ob die usa zugeständnisse macht
den ist der datenschutz eigentlich fremd
die haben eine ganz andere rechts
tradition und vor den wahlen wird er
wohl kaum was passieren also bist du ein
abkommen steht werden viele unternehmen
noch sehr viel ärger mit dem datenschutz
halten und trotzdem ist es ein ganz
wichtiges sie sagen historisches urteil
vielen dank felix zimmermann zu dem
thema haben wir auch online viele
informationen zu bieten weitere
erklärungen und einschätzungen zum
datenschutz und den konsequenzen dieses
urteils finden sie in der zdf heute und
hier geht es jetzt erst mal weiter mit
nachrichten bundestag aus deutschlands
größter schlacht konzern turniers hat
nach vierwöchiger zwangspause den
betrieb am stammsitz in rheda
wiedenbrück wieder aufgenommen
rund 600 mitarbeiter durften auf das
gelände zurückkehren
unter strengen hygiene auflagen wie
regelmäßigen corona tests parallel dazu
demonstrierten umweltaktivisten für
einen grundlegenden wandel in der
fleischindustrie 8000 schweine wurden
heute in einer ersten schicht
geschlachtet die zerlegung geht morgen
in einen probebetrieb
das werk war geschlossen worden nachdem
sich mehr als 1500 mitarbeiter mit
corona infiziert hatten britische
behörden werfen hacker vor
im auftrag moskaus weltweit
cyberspionage weil impfstoffforschung zu
betreiben seit beginn der pandemie
versuche eine hacker-gruppe daten aus
forschungseinrichtungen zu stehlen
es sei beinahe sicher dass diese gruppe
als teil von russischen geheimdiensten
aktiv sei erklärte das britische zentrum
für cyber sicherheit moskau bestreitet
diese vorwürfe
kriminelle haben mehrere twitter konten
von us firmen und prominenten
fact betroffen waren unter anderem
microsoft gründer bill gates amazon chef
bezos und ex präsident barack obama die
hacker fälschten über deren profile
botschaften wer die krypto währung
bitcoin überweise er halte die doppelte
summe zurück mehr als 100.000 dollar
wurden so erbeutet wittert sperrte die
konten und sagte aufklärung zu erneut
sind rechtsextreme droh mails an
politikerinnen der linken und an eine
kabarettistin verschickt worden wieder
mit dem absender nsu 2.0
adressaten sind diesmal auch die zdf
moderatorin maybrit illner und die taz
journalistin jacobi fahrer der stil
entsprechenden anonymen mails die auch
an die hessische linken politikerin
wissler gingen so die staatsanwaltschaft
in frankfurt am main
mehr als 1000 menschen haben in moskau
und sankt petersburg gegen russlands
präsident putin demonstriert hunderte
kreml-kritiker trafen sich im zentrum
der hauptstadt zu unangemeldeten
protesten
sie wollten unterschriften für eine
petition gegen die umstrittene
verfassungsreform sammeln
mit dem ziel einer möglichen berufung
vor dem obersten gericht die polizei
nahm mindestens 130 demonstranten fest
seit fast zwei wochen ist die neue
verfassung in kraft sie erweitert putins
macht und ermöglicht ihm amtszeiten bis
damit war zu rechnen in einer zeit in
der es um das deutsch türkische
verhältnis ohnehin schlecht bestellt ist
viel heute das urteil gegen den
weltranglisten- deniz yücel das
istanbuler schwurgericht verurteilte ihn
zu abwesenheit in abwesenheit zu zwei
jahren und neun monaten haft wegen
angeblicher terror propaganda für die
kurdische arbeiterpartei pkk
wegen dieses und anderer vorwürfe hatte
ual ein jahr in türkischer
untersuchungshaft gesessen seine
inhaftierung schon damals ein skandal
das urteil heute unter rechtsstaatlichen
gesichtspunkten eine farce katrin
eigendorf berichtet
das land ist so etwas wie die grand dame
im türkischen journalismus 45 jahre ist
sie dabei vom oppositions- sender halb
tv moderiert sie das mittagsmagazin
fast jeden tag berichten sie über
inhaftierte kollegen der fall dennis
mitchell ist dennoch ein besonderer für
sie dennis mitchell hat in diesem land
gesagt der könig ist nackt seine
erfahrungen wurden zu einem symbol dafür
was mit den medien in der türkei
passiert haftstrafe für journalismus
zwei jahre und neun monate gefängnis für
ein interview mit dem anführer der
kurdischen pkk schimmel barrique dass
das gericht als terror propaganda
verurteilt
außerdem so medienanwalt welche knox
soll gegen gicquel in zwei weiteren
fällen ermittelt werden wegen
präsidenten beleidigung
dieser fall war von anfang an ein
politischer prozess die parteien in
diesem prozess waren die türkische
regierung die exekutive und der
präsident tatsächlich hatte präsident
erdogan den deutsch türkischen
journalisten persönlich zum staatsfeind
erklärt und als agenten bezeichnet so
lange er im amt sei werde nicht
freigelassen
ein jahr lang saß der korrespondent der
tageszeitung welt ohne anklage im
hochsicherheitsgefängnis sie live in
istanbul
erst auf massiven druck der
bundesregierung kam für joel februar
2018 frei er musste sich verpflichten
die türkei sofort zu verlassen
per skype sprechen wir mit ihm in berlin
er will weiter um ein gerechtes urteil
kämpfen ich bin mir absolut sicher dass
früher verfassungsgericht wurde zum
öffentlichen gerichtshof für
menschenrechte am ende hieß es verbrannt
so enden ist heute müssen nämlich alle
preis
kritik an der regierung wird zunehmend
gefährlich halte tv berichtet dennoch
kritisch so zum beispiel über die hagia
sophia die erdogan in eine moschee
umwandeln lässt eine entscheidung die
die bevölkerung spaltet das zu benennen
ist schon mutig wie sagte george
ich kann nicht atmen in der türkei
können wir journalisten nicht mehr atmen
pressefreiheit und rechtsstaatlichkeit
sind in der türkei bedroht auch das ist
das signal heute aus dem istanbuler
schwurgericht anwalt bachelot will gegen
das urteil vorgehen der fall ist noch
lange nicht abgeschlossen
nachfrage bei katrin eigendorf in
istanbul
katrin der deutsche außenminister maas
hat das urteil scharf kritisiert die
türkische justiz ende hier ein falsches
signal
als anwalt wird der berufung gehen kann
dass erfolg haben
wir müssen im moment davon ausgehen dass
man von der justiz in der türkei kein
unabhängiges urteil erwarten kann das
betrifft fälle wie deniz yücel das
betrifft journalisten wie metalle tolo
aber auch menschenrechtler die hier noch
künftig vor gericht stehen werden wir
müssen davon ausgehen dass erdogan diese
politischen urteile auch in zukunft
weiter durchsetzen will deswegen bin ich
äußerst skeptisch dass auf dem rechtsweg
in der türkei ein freispruch für deniz
yücel solutions zu erzielen ist man muss
ja sehen
dieser fall war ja ein ganz besonderer
erst war ja im prinzip die spitze des
eisberges der die deutsch türkischen
beziehungen auch extrem belastet hat die
bundesregierung hat wiederholt sehr sehr
starken druck ausgeübt das alles hat
wenig gefruchtet im moment sieht es so
aus dass der türkische präsident erdogan
wohl in kauf nimmt international in
konfrontation zu gehen das zeigt ja
unter anderem auch der fall der hagia
sophia der in eine moschee umwandeln
will trotz internationaler starker
kritik
also wir müssen davon ausgehen die
türkische justiz wird weiter in den
händen erdogans sein und unabhängige
urteile eine unabhängige justiz sehe ich
im
hier nicht dankeschön katrin eigendorf
nach istanbul über massnahmen gegen das
grüner virus haben wir eingangs schon
berichtet jetzt geht es um eine branche
die als eine von wenigen noch keine
lockerung erfahren hat und zwar die die
man landläufig die älteste der welt
nennt bordellbetriebe sind seit mitte
märz bundesweit geschlossen und das
scheint ja irgendwie auch schlüssig das
gewerbe ist naturgemäß auf das gegenteil
angewiesen von abstandsregeln klar ist
aber die prostitution geht weiter auch
in corona zeiten und wird in die
illegalität gedrängt susanne genath
berichtet kein sex nur information bei
lauras girls in speyer möchten sie mit
dem tag der offenen tür auf die
situation der bordelle aufmerksam machen
seit vier monaten geschlossen wegen
corona viele prostituierte sind
finanziell am ende und arbeiten nun
illegal und illegalität bedeutet immer
schutzloser raum egal in welcher
situation sie den freier in dunklen
ecken empfängt um ihr passiert was sie
kann sich nicht wehren sie kann nicht
zur polizei war sie natürlich
gewalttätig ist etwa 33.000
prostituierte sind in deutschland
offiziell registriert die meisten
arbeiten in clubs die dunkelziffer der
illegalen ist um ein vielfaches höher
und wächst mit den corona schließungen
dabei könnten bordelle strenge hygiene
regeln einhalten meint laura abstand
masken pflicht bei erotischen massagen
auch eine registrierung sei möglich man
kennt sich ja teilweise schon über jahre
und jahrzehnte bald und wir haben auch
vorher schon sehr viel über termin
gearbeitet also wir haben stammkunden
die rufen natürlich an und wollen den
termin vereinbaren
und es ist kein problem die
telefonnummer notieren bordelle seien
gefährliche infektionsherde meint eine
gruppe von 16 bundestagsabgeordneten
sie lehnt eine öffnung ab und will
langfristig ein verbot der prostitution
mit ausstiegshilfen für die betroffenen
frauen
man kann die prostitution nicht
verbieten ohne dass man prostituierten
etwas anbietet was ihnen also eine
existenzgrundlage verschafft das sind um
schulen sind voll das sind andere berufe
im berliner bordell rose halten sie das
für unrealistisch und fordern mit ihrer
aktion heute stattdessen bessere
arbeitsbedingungen
verbote generell das zeigt auch corona
führen nicht dazu dass prostitution
unterbunden wird sondern prostitution
hat zu allen zeiten in allen ländern
seinen weg gefunden es gibt genug
menschen die es ausüben und genug
menschen die es in anspruch nehmen
rheinland pfalz hat als erstes
bundesland eine wiedereröffnung der
bordelle ins gespräch gebracht um den
betroffenen eine perspektive zu geben
voraussetzung bundesweite abstimmung und
niedrige infektionszahlen insgesamt
haben wir als gesellschaft das problem
dass wir ein ambivalentes ein
gespaltenes verhältnis zum thema
prostitution haben
und da sehe ich die gefahr dass manche
jetzt auch die korona pandemie als hebel
nutzen wollen die prostitution insgesamt
auch in frage zu stellen und das geht
natürlich überhaupt nicht offene
bordelle also vielleicht schon bald bei
lauras girls ist man darauf vorbereitet
weitere nachrichten jetzt mit gundula
gause an den finanzmärkten hörte man
heute auf die worte der ezb-präsident in
lagarde die europäische zentralbank
beschloss auf ihrer zinssitzung an ihrem
kurs in der korona krise festzuhalten
die leitzinsen bleiben unverändert die
anleihekäufe gehen weiter weil er die
halle was erwartet die ezb von dem eu
gipfel der morgen in brüssel beginnt ja
sie erwartet dass jetzt erst mal die
politik ihre hausaufgaben macht deswegen
möchte präsidentin la gare dass man sich
beim eu-gipfel möglichst schnell auf
einen corona hilfsverein nicht allen
nationalen vorbehalten zum trotz die ezb
springt der eurozone ja schon massiv bei
über eine billion euro gibt sie aus für
staats- und unternehmen
anleihen ein hilfsprogramm das alles in
den schatten stellt was sie bisher in
einer krise aufgeboten hat für dieses
jahr rechnet die ezb mit einer schweren
rezession im euroraum um 8,7 prozent
soll die konjunktur in der euro-zone
schrumpfen laut ezb geht es wieder
aufwärts besonders italien und spanien
erholen sich aber nur langsam
kraftvolle anstrengungen aller 27 eu
staaten seien nötig um die
konjunkturerholung zu begleiten
das hilfsprogramm der ezb läuft noch bis
zum sommer nächsten jahres notfalls kann
und wird sie noch mal nachlegen
das wird vermutlich nötig sein wenn eine
zweite pandemiewelle wieder weite teile
der wirtschaft lahm legt der dax hat
sich von corona schock schon längst
erholt heute allerdings ein wenig
zurückhaltung aber das allzeithoch von
13.000 ist schon greifbar nah vielen
dank ballerina frankfurt im bilanz
skandal um den mutmaßlichen
milliardenbetrug beim dax-konzern
wirecard will der bundesrechnungshof
prüfen wie die finanzaufsicht bafin und
das bundesfinanzministerium mit den
vorwürfen falscher bilanzen und den
berichten der wirtschaftsprüfer
umgegangen sind zugleich wurde heute
bekannt dass bundesfinanzminister scholz
bereits seit eineinhalb jahren von einem
verdacht der bafin gegen wirecard wusste
vor fünf monaten startete die esa
raumsonde solar orbiter ins all ihre
mission die erforschung der sonne
jetzt schickt sie erstmals bilder des
glühenden gas bald an das
satellitenkontrollzentrum in darmstadt
soonahe aufgenommen wie nie zuvor aus
einer entfernung von nur 77 millionen
kilometern
besonders spektakulär für die forscher
die aufnahmen von kleinen
sonneneruptionen sogenannten lagerfeuern
an der oberfläche
fans von vereinen der ersten und zweiten
fußball bundesliga dürfen hoffen
die dfl hat einen leitfaden für eine
rückkehr ins stadion erstellt auf dessen
grundlage sollen die klubs gemeinsam mit
den lokalen gesundheitsbehörden konzepte
entwickeln
berücksichtigt werden müssen
sicherheitsabstände auf den tribünen
eine geregelte an und abreise ein
alkoholverbot sowie das lokale
infektionsgeschehen nur bei unter 35
neuinfektionen und pro 100.000
einwohnern in den vergangenen sieben
tagen seien spiele mit zuschauern
denkbar
man kann wieder ins kino gehen und wir
hätten da eine empfehlung
sie ist eine der berühmtesten
wissenschaftlerinnen der welt und hat
geschafft was bis heute außergewöhnlich
ist marie curie gewann zweimal den
nobelpreis 1903 in physik 1911 dann in
chemie
das war eine sensation und ist es bis
heute nur 20 mal wurde der nobelpreis in
den kategorien physik chemie und medizin
überhaupt an eine frau verliehen
596 preisträger waren männlich auch
marie curie musste für den erfolg
kämpfen ihr nicht immer leichtes leben
ist jetzt neu verfilmt worden elemente
des lebens kommt heute in die kinos ob
er auch als ermunterung für alle
abiturientinnen taugt die jetzt nach
einem studienfach suchen
anna zimmermann berichtet sie macht eine
bahnbrechende entdeckung und wonach
suchen sie ich möchte die strahlung polo
raten stellen dabei fest dass es
wesentlich geringer strahlt als ein
ärzten
mein gefühl sagt mir dass da noch ein
weiteres element ist dass die ergebnisse
verzerrt sie denken an ein unbekanntes
neues element marie curie ist es die die
elemente polonium und radium entdeckt
gemeinsam mit ihrem mann care
sie ist eine herausragende
wissenschaftlerinnen die allerdings
immer wieder auf gegen sind stößt als
frau in einer absoluten männerdomäne und
nichts anderes ist die welt der
wissenschaft zur jahrhundertwende
nein wir bieten ihnen nichts wenn meine
arbeiten meine befähigung dafür nicht
ausreichend belegen
dann haben sie grundsätzlich falsch
verstanden ich bitte um entschuldigung
man sieht sie wie immer verhalten
regisseurin mariana therapie gelingt es
einen komplexen charakter zu zeichnen
überzeugend gespielt von rosamund pike
was ich wirklich an ihr mag neben der
tatsache dass sie eine brillante
wissenschaftlerin war
sie war extrem kämpferisch und
kompromisslos sie hätte das alles nicht
geschafft wenn sie nicht so gewesen wäre
marie curie war die erste frau überhaupt
die einen nobelpreis gewonnen hat doch
erst sollte eigentlich nur ihr mann
ausgezeichnet werden
ich bin die frau richtig kommt stuttgart
und auch nur er konnte damals sich zur
preisverleihung fahren war brillanz
gestohlen sie für deine ausgegeben du
hättest nie allein dorthin fahren dürfen
du wartest gerade ein kind zur welt
gebracht du warst zu krank um zu reisen
und außerdem wolltest du nicht mitfahren
wie hätte ich mich dann verhalten soll
marie curie es kampf um anerkennung in
der wissenschaft ist noch immer aktuell
im jahr 2018 war nur knapp ein viertel
der professoren in deutschland mit
frauen besetzt und nobelpreisträgerinnen
gibt es bis heute nur weniger
das sieht man die unterschiedliche
gewichtigkeit die sich auch ausdrückt in
der repräsentanz von frauen
beispielsweise in akademien der
wissenschaft was ich auch heute noch
durch bezieht ist die sorge für die
kinder marie curie
eine alleinerziehende mutter weil man zu
früh gestorben ist
auch das ist etwas was wir wollten auch
in der wissenschaft sehen dass die
frauen die wissenschaftlerinnen für die
kinder zuständig sind
der film will viel in knapp 110 minuten
er zeigt marie curie als hoch
intelligente wissenschaftlerin als
privatperson und außerdem die folgen
ihrer entdeckung das ist der
experimentelle teil des films immer
wieder springt die regisseuren dafür in
die zukunft
das geschieht zum teil unvermittelt kann
manch einen zuschauer irritieren
es zeigt aber auch die dimension des
wirkens von marie curie bis heute so
nicht dass sie jetzt noch weitergeben an
die kolleginnen dunja hayali die heute
in ihre sommer staffel startet mit
wirklich eindrucksvollen reportagen und
interessanten gästen darunter heute der
siemens chef joe kaeser wir wünschen
einen schönen sieht so ist es bis morgen
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren hier über
dem atlantik da liegt schon das
wochenend-wetter mit dem hoch cbd ops
bevor das sich aber zu uns durch selbst
müssen wir erst noch etwas regen über
uns ergehen lassen mit diesem tief das
ab zieht der regen fällt vor allen
dingen am alpenrand es gibt allerdings
morgen auch im nordosten deutschlands
einige schauer und gewitter heute nacht
also fällt noch ergiebiger regen an den
alpen sonst lassen die regenfälle
allmählich nach an der elbe bleibt es
klar und zum teil bildet sich im
sauerland auch mal nebel an der elbe
sinken die temperaturen auf null bis
sieben grad das ist wirklich cool 14
grad sind es dagegen an der ostsee oder
auch am oberrhein und morgen klettern
die temperaturen dann doch für uns meist
über 20 grad im vogtland und auf den
ostfriesischen inseln sind das nur so 19
grad im rhein-main-gebiet dagegen werden
es bis zu 25 grad am kühlsten bleibt es
am alpenrand mit nur 18 grad denn dort
regnet es morgen noch am längsten weiter
sonst ist es mal mehr mal weniger stark
bewölkt und im osten fällt etwas regen
nachmittags ist doch mal ein gewitter
dabei der samstag wird dann für uns doch
schon viel freundlicher der sonntag
bringt einige regenschauer und gewitter
bis zu 30 grad und am montag erwischt
uns dann von nord westen eine kaltfront
und daher sinken dann die temperaturen
wie sie hier am beispiel von berlin
sehen können zur wochenmitte deutlich
unter 20 grad danach aber geht es doch
mit gemäßigter sommerwärme weiter
schönen abend noch